hello everyone and welcome back to our
coverage of the 2023 national
championships we're in studio with Jana
Thomas Jana welcome to the
show I know you've been working with
Kate but you have been going into the
schools yes for the last six years and
now you're a coordinator with school
program tell us about all the work that
you do for the club and for the schools
and the kids okay well now as a
coordinator my job is is to go out to
these many districts and work with the
principals and the teachers to get these
programs started so children can learn
and practice chess exactly yeah yeah so
since St Louis chess club mission is
deeply rooted in educating about a uh
game of chess what do you like the most
about teaching chess well I love how it
relates to life so I mean I've been in
education over 20 years don't tell me
but I I just loved how I could relate
life lessons to the chessboard and it
really made it relatable for children
and you know they seem to catch on a lot
faster when when the lessons are
meaningful right you know yeah so I
really enjoy that and I know of course
uh besides just going out during school
hours and stuff like that you guys have
actually been coordinating uh also for
summer school camps and you had I know
every week during summer there is a camp
one week we had over 100 Kids signed up
I would do a face plan if I had to take
care of 100 Kids huge huge teamwork here
you know working with the grand Masters
and our other instructors yeah it was a
huge undertaking but it was great we
served so many children I mean how much
feedback do you get from parents about
these camps how do kids love it well in
the summer camp time you know we had
children and parents telling us that
their child told them this was the best
week of my life Wow Wow yeah that's
really really nice as we see some of uh
the b-rolls from uh chess camps uh that
have taken place at the chess club can
you fit a 100 kids in the St Louis chess
club I mean that's hard right that's a
lot of kids yeah not right now we can't
but soon soon we will be able to oh my
good I remember some of the parents
telling me that they drop off kids at
8:00 a.m. uh for the uh for the camp
they pick them up around 400 p.m. and
once the kids get back uh get back to
home they play chess they try to play
against their parents against siblings
and parents were like what is happening
here right exactly um Community day that
was a big Outreach and I think for a lot
of the grand Masters they really enjoy
going out and seeing the kids faces cuz
the kids faces light they light up like
light bulb what what give give us the
kids reaction what do they think when
they when they have a Katrina come into
the classroom and they see a Grandmaster
well they are are so excited they you
know when I walked in with them they're
like oh can we have your autograph I
said you know I'm not a grandmas but
I'll give you my autograph it might be
something one day but they're so excited
they're asking for autographs and they
are actually in certain instances able
to see a reflection of themselves like
when we have a woman grandmas that's
13 oh you know children are like it's
possible it's possible when we have of
course you're talking about exactly when
we have a the youngest International
Master 14 children are like wow that's
crazy maybe you know maybe I can do this
one day because these are people who
have reached the goal that maybe they
Aspire exactly and they get to ask them
questions right so they were super
excited it was special is there like a
school league where the other schools
compete against each other the kids want
to be on the team to play against the
other schools yes so I mean with their
schools they they play with their school
Scholastics puts on monthly tournaments
so our students in our programs get to
come out and then take their chess to
the next level and compete wonderful how
many coaches are going out in the
schools H now that's a hard number to
because we I know it's a big number it's
always going every adding seasonality is
a big deal too yeah it is but it's well
above two
dozen yeah well above two doen and J you
used to be a coach now you are a
coordinator the school year is starting
what can kids be looking forward in this
new school year oh well you know lots of
programming our tournaments that's
something that's huge we are definitely
trying to push for more and more of the
students that we have in our programs to
come out to our monthly tournaments um
and then we also team up with certain
districts and have special tournaments
so yeah we're just trying to get them
more
involved jna thank you so much for
coming on and And discussing with our
audience what been doing and what the St
Louis chess club is doing thank you for
everything you do for the community
thank you absolutely and let's take a
look at our standings uh will